hey everyone Peter Brown here with a
gamespot news update according to
multiple media outlet reports anti
gaming senator leland yee was arrested
today on bribery and corruption charges
he was arrested this morning by the FBI
in a sting operation in San Francisco's
Chinatown we've tried contacting a
representative of ye but have not
received a response ye a democratic
california state senator is known to
gamers for putting forth the
much-publicized violent video game law
that the United States Supreme Court
struck down in 2011 following the
december two thousand twelve schoolhouse
massacre in newtown connecticut ye again
criticized gamers and the industry at
large ye said at the time gamers have
just got to quiet down gamers have no
credibility in this argument this is all
about their lust for violence and the
industry's lust for money this is a
billion-dollar industry this is about
their self-interest he's got the lust
for money now huh anyway stay tuned to
gamespot com for more updates as they
occur